real talk uh i don't have a card
collection i don't drive cars i don't do
mountain climbing i don't do parasailing
i don't i just i like hanging out with
people and i had a party for my 40th
birthday a year or so ago
and i remember at the birthday party i
was newly single because i had a girl
for a little while didn't work out but i
remember at my 40th birthday party i had
a bunch of friends people showed up it
was great shout out to bodega in south
beach if you ever want to go
uh and i remember a friend coming up to
me and then being like dude adam you're
40 bro you're killing it you're making
money you're the freaking man like
hyping me up gassing me up right you
know this that the others like yo i want
to be you kind of i was like i respect
bro and he goes oh is that so and so
over there am i going to say her name i
mean i remember her from high school
what's she up to i'm like oh i don't
know like he's like is she married yet i
go no i don't think so he goes man
feel bad for her and i go what do you
mean you feel bad for her and he's like
and essentially he was like at 40 a guy
you could be like a stud or a pimp or
whatever kind of and at 40 for a female
he was like
where and that made me feel horrible for
her and it kind of was because i felt
kind of weird at 40 single whatever
successful but there is a difference
between a guy who's 40 and a girl is 40.
do you guys agree or disagree absolutely
because for at 40 for a woman it's
basically over
really yeah i mean guys as far as having
kids guys are having kids and like
physically for most women yeah i mean
there's exceptions sure but that's not
the rule but as a 40 year old guy that
like you know if you're doing pretty
well you could get married tomorrow with
25 year olds have five kids and still
have a whole life that's just not the
case biologically for women yeah
that's true
comments i think it's sad and also in
some way i think it's embarrassing for
women that are put in those situations
because how do you make it to 40 and not
learn how to get along with a man
how do you make it that far and you just
never pick up on cues and some sometimes
these women have children and that's
great and you know sometimes they don't
have a man but sometimes they don't have
either which one they're just absolutely
by themselves and so like is is that a
full life because so they have
girlfriends that's great but are all of
those girlfriends single or are they
also like married with children or they
have professions it seems lonely to me
and i think women come out and they try
to say that it's not and i think it's a
cope you can see it on the tick tock
pages like look at me i'm so happy i'm
drinking wine and i'm 40 and i'm single
if you're so happy why do you have to
make your entire take talk page and your
idea i'll tell you i'm not gonna say
this girl's name but i'll give you a
very clear example of someone that every
time like
oh damn you
she was one of the hottest girls in high
school
grew up you know in her 20s guys were
throwing themselves left and right she
had her pick of the letter by 30 she was
still out there in south beach doing her
thing still didn't have a man and then i
didn't see her for many years right
she i think she lived in new york doing
her thing but then i ran into her i
don't know maybe
like three-ish years ago and she was in
her late 30s early 40s
now
the dude that she was like the guys that
were pursuing her certified studs in
their 20s or
now
essentially she's like hey what's up
with your friend over there and like
this guy i wouldn't say he's a stunt
so now the girl who was 21 25 even 30
that had her pick of the litter
has to realize that at 40 the studs
aren't exactly throwing themselves on
her anymore well that's something a
woman had to deal with and i felt like
so i was like shoot
and i told the guy because i'm friends
with the guy because he was like what's
up i was like dude you understand in
high school college she was like the
hottest chick he's like yeah but but
that's not that's 20 years ago bro but
but why did you feel bad for her that
was her choice she's right here she made
her bed lie in it i don't know i didn't
lose sleep over it but i constantly
think of it because these are now that
i'm 41 i i know girls in their late 30s
early 40s were still single and i'm like
go ahead coco i don't know if i you know
struck a chord there but go ahead no no
no no it's for this she's 31 she's not
60.
i don't i do not care about being 40 and
whatever question for uh them
would you let's say if you get a divorce
would you
consider that as defeat like you didn't
yes yeah yeah you should be upset i am
divorced
that that's a ding on my record that
that is a failure i failed i mean he
also failed you know i've not been out
of shape about it because i got the man
in my dreams but you should
look at divorce as a failure i don't
know why you wouldn't yeah you chose
poorly and now you've wasted each
other's time
interesting interesting would you say
it's a failure if you were
um able to
uh give birth to children and like your
children ended up in like a good place
and they have a successful
future
in the sense like for example like you
have people who get married and then
they find out this other person is not
who they are right and then kids come
out of it right and the kids turn out
great successful and all that stuff
would you still say
that it was a failure or would you say
that there was it's a success no it's
still a failure it's beautiful that the
children are here most parents don't
regret their kids that innately but it
is still a failure you chose poorly you
reproduce now these children don't have
a father in the home but we're so used
to it we think that it's okay but the
outcomes are still negative like i grew
up in a single mother home i i had a lot
of risk factors that i had to solve
myself in the dating market
and that's something that doesn't get
talked about it's all about this eat
pray love and that's not to say you know
stay in a relationship and be miserable
but sometimes you got to make your bed
and lie in it and you got to be
roommates well because
when you have kids it's not about you
anymore